Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich hoffe du hast genug Sonne.
Zu viel Sonne habe ich ich musste den Vorhang schließen und ich prangere das an so will ich nie wieder in Echo verliehen bekommen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 250.
Ja und wir haben alle Echos zurückgegeben.
Nein wir haben nun hast du ein Echo Tim.
Nee ich habe mal den Preis gekriegt.
Nee ich meine diese Amazon Dinger.
Achso so in Essen sondern sprechen Sie Linda.
Wir können uns Rügen nie ein Echo gehabt zu haben.
Mal gucken wir unsere Verbindung ja heute läuft wir nehmen ja heute mal aus der Ferne auf der Haut können wir es ja mal sagen.
Ja heute kann man das noch mal sagen wie oft wir voneinander getrennt sind und doch im Internet Verein das Internet bringt die Menschen näher zueinander.
Was stimmt was stimmt.
Wir leben es.
Ja 250 Sendung wir wollen heute nicht so viel,
seitdem einräumen wie schön es doch war und überhaupt so der typische Jubiläums Klimbim das schieben wir dann bewusst auf unsere live on stage Sendung 256.
Die sehen Planung befindet und von der wir hoffen dass ihr zahlreich dran teilnehmen werdet und wie schon letztes Mal erwähnt Tickets in der Woche ja.
26.04.
Genau ist unser Ziel Dart.
Keine relativen Zeitangaben in Podcast den 500 Jahren noch gehört werden der sky.
Hihihihi 2018/2018.
26.04 2016 tickets.
Ihr ihr wisst schon Menschen aus der Zukunft dieses komische Jahrtausend dieses komische jahrhundert irgendwie dass so viele Umbrüche gebracht hat aber von der wir euch von der wir uns dann am Ende doch noch frei schütteln konnten.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Genau 26.Mai LMP2 156.
Kannst ja viele beschweren dass wir nicht auf den 25.06 gewahrt.
Das wäre der Tat elegant gewesen aber das hätte dann doch eine längere Verzögerung der Sendung zwischendurch bedeutet,
mal gucken wir werden das nächste Mal versuchen unsere nummerologie noch ein bisschen mehr in Form zu bringen jetzt bist du erstmal damit leben.
Kommen wir zum Feedback wir können ja versuchen die die 512 an einem 512 zu feiern vielleicht können wir das hin.
Andreas passen zur Ankündigung des.
LMP 250 Events in Babylon hat Bayern 2 ein passendes Kalenderblatt zu dessen Geschichte veröffentlicht das Babylon ein Lichtspiel Palast für,
1200 Zuschauer 1 auch geheimer Treffpunkt für den Widerstand gegen die Nazis heute Austragungsort der 256 Sendung Logbuch Netzpolitik und,
der Berlinale.
Das liest sich der Kreis genauso ein paar Minuten.
Am 1200 wo sind die denn.
Ja ursprünglich war das tatsächlich mal sehr viel dichter bestuhlt und vor allem gab es oben also Schlüssel klassisches Theater oben mit Rang und der Rang war noch deutlich besser als das heute ist das ist das aus statischen Gründen mal etwas zurück gebaut worden,
und unten wohnen dann die Sitzreihen auch ausgedünnt und so hat es halt nur noch knapp die Hälfte dieser Kapazität bisschen weniger so.
Das heißt es eigentlich jetzt Business Class.
Slowenia.
Ja gut dann ziehen wir die Preise an.
Genau.
Und Jörg kommentiert relativ lange ich nehme nur einige Teile daraus.
Auch wenn ich damit hier wohl einen Shitstorm auslösen anderes gibt keine Schätzung,
möchte ich dafür werben nicht alle Facebook-Nutzer als unreflektierte vom eigenen Geltungsdrang entmündigte Netz Idioten zu kopieren sondern in Betracht zu ziehen,
dass sich in diesem Netzwerk auch Menschen bewegen die sich über das Metall Jungs wurde von Facebook weitgehend im Klaren sind den persönlichen Nutzen,
den sie mit den angebotenen Diensten erfahren aber als so hoch einschätzen dass sie einen gewissen Verlust an Kontrolle innere Daten bewusst in Kauf nehmen.
Weiterhin den Sinn von Facebook aber allein auf dem Metallisierung suspect zu reduzieren der arbeit aber jeglichen positiven Nutzen für die Mitglieder zu negieren finde ich etwas überheblich den jeder,
kann noch für sich selbst entscheiden wie wichtig Anonymität und Datensparsamkeit für ihnen gegenüber Selbstdarstellung Meinungsaustausch und Kontaktpflege sind.
Darf ich Einwände.
Ja ich auch das ist eigentlich also ich meine gibt's dieses schöneworth login ja also nicht das mit G das mit CK,
dennis hat ja nun auch nicht unbedingt jeder die Wahl also manche machen die Wahl und ab einer bestimmten Füllungen des Raumes müssen alle anderen auch noch mit rein.
Das ist schon mal ein Aspekt davon und meine ist auch nicht so dass uns nicht klar wäre warum Facebook erfolgreich ist.
Ja ich meinem wesentlichen kann man auch sagen es ist alles das Scheitern des Netzes drumherum was halt nicht in der Lage war für so grundlegende Dienstleistung wie E-Mail Messaging,
und Posting von Veranstaltungen z.b. brauchbare leicht zu benutzende und interoperabel funktionierende Lösung anzubieten das war alles sehr viel Gefrickel und Pumuckl man muss ich nur mal den Zustand von E-Mail noch heute anschauen nachdem es Facebook schon so lange gibt,
das ist eigentlich ein Desaster und von daher waren eigentlich die Türen offen für einen Anbieter darein zu marschieren und Facebook ist halt die jenige der son.
Bekanntesten gemacht hat sehen.
Trotzdem würde ich natürlich sagen also,
facebook hat sich den Vorteil genutzt in den technisch strategischen Vorteil das ganz einfach zentralisiert zu machen das hat den Vorteil dass es im Zweifelsfall besser funktioniert und skaliert als dezentrales System skaliert im Sinne von wenn man Änderungen und Updates macht ne wenn Facebook sagt ab heute,
machen wir das oben anders sonst sieht die Leiste anders aus dann ist das eben so für alle ja wenn man wenn E-Mail sagt ab heute ist alles verschlüsselt dann funktioniert es in 25 Jahren nicht ne.
Und dann natürlich noch den Vorteil dass es eben auch monetarisierbar ist aber was Facebook,
benutzen liefert das ginge ja auch ohne dieses monetarisierungs mit hätte auch ein anderes geben können,
tim war ja z.b. großer Fan von dieser Idee von app.net wo man irgendwie fütter zum Bezahlen so ungefähr hat die,
der Gedanke Teil das was facebook ist quasi zu bauen in Datenschutz freundlich und in.
Im in anders monetarisiert da gibt es viele Möglichkeiten die wir als Menschheit alle auf den einen oder den anderen Weg versäumt haben.
Und drittens würde ich auch noch widersprechen dass hier jeder einzelne jeder einzelne Nutzen der Person von Facebook eine individuelle.
Risikoabschätzung trifft sich spätestens wenn wir über so Sachen wie.
Cambridge analytica und Wahlmanipulation und ähnliche Dinge sprechen und mindestens Risiko im Raum ist und vor allem wenn wir so viel zentralisiert macht bei einem Unternehmen haben,
dann ist das keine Frage des individuellen Risikos mehr ja das ist das Risiko wenn ich.
Was heißt ich Idiot werde und mich politisch unsinnig verhalte wenn ich wenn meine.
Wenn ich eines von vielen manipulierten,
eine von vier manipulierten Personen bin ist mein individuelles Risiko oder mein individueller erscheinen bei weitem nicht so groß wie der kollektiver.
Und diese Einflussmöglichkeiten die zentralisierte Datenhaltung die wir Facebook eingeräumt haben die ist,
das eigentliche Problem dieses Unternehmens und das ist auch der Grund warum wir auf das Unternehmen viel mehr eindreschen als jetzt auf chemisch Analytiker die letztendlich Facebook benutzt haben so wie es gedacht war.
Ja also ich meine die Annahme dass jeder sich dessen bewusst ist worin er sich damit gibt so dass das mag bei einigen sicherlich so sein aber das ist unter Garantie nicht beeilen so und,
auch wenn unsere Kreise da schon oft geklagt uns gewarnt haben,
damit erreicht man natürlich erstens nicht jeden und zweitens denke ich mal.
Haben wir auch viele auch bewusst weg gehört wenn man ja einfach in dieser Zwickmühle ist na was machst du denn wenn deine deine deine Elternversammlung an der Schule und wieso eine Facebook-Gruppe benutzt um dann irgendwie die wichtigen Schule Informationen auszutauschen nicht daran teilnehmen,
so schwierig na also wir sagen nicht hier gibt's noch einfacher Antwort aber.
Ich denke dass die Kritik an Facebook so oder so angemessen ist.
Wenn Sie diesen lock-in-effekt ist noch zusammen deswegen werden ja jetzt auch die genau wegen den nächsten Gruppen und den den den dem Problem dass es kaum noch möglich ist nicht auf Facebook zu sein,
genau deswegen werden ja auch jetzt diese rufe laut zur Regulierung Zerschlagung und sonstigen von von diesem Unternehmen.
Ja wir bleiben bei Facebook denke ich mal da gibt es einiges zu berichten.
Unter anderem hat nun der von uns ja auch angekündigte und weltweit ja auch viel Beachtung gefunden im Auftritt von Zuckerberg im amerikanischen Senat.
Stattgefunden da Sasa dann auf seinem dicken Lederkissen sich noch mal 20 cm größer zu machen.
Mitterreith was Statur beweisen kann.
Und das war eine denkwürdige Veranstaltung würde ich sagen er sagt da irgendwie fünf Stunden.
Wann hat sich je von 129 Senatoren hat irgendwie je fünf Minuten Zeit ihn zu befragen.
Armin alles mögliche gefragt du hast es nicht gesehen ne.
Ich habe nur Ausschnitte und Zusammenschlüsse davon gesehen aber das war ja auch schon also der schönste Ausschnitt ist ja dass dieser eine in dieser eine Senator gefragt wie ihr denn beabsichtigt diese Dienstleistungen weiterhin kostenlos anzubieten.
Hat er einfach nur antwortet cinetech was natürlich.
Also das zeigte der dass ich auch dass nicht alle in diesem Senat in der Lage waren die jetzt besonders scharfe Fragen zu stellen.
Ja dass das war das Wasser über die sehr auf Elias ich habe ungefähr nur so die erste Hälfte gesehen so zwei zweieinhalb Stunden irgendwie sowas dann war ich dann zu müde das war ja dann hier tief in der Nacht das kann man mehreren Stellen durch also entweder.
Waren die Fragen einfach nicht besonders soll ich sagen nicht besonders fordernd gestellt.
Teilweise ging die heute auch wie diese typische.
Technikbegriff Verteilung Soja was ist denn wenn ich jetzt eine E-Mail in WhatsApp verschicke und so.
War schon klar wurde so so richtig durchdrungen hat die Person oder auch die Mitarbeiter die sich die Frage ausgesagt haben das ganze nicht,
ich vermisse schockiert weil wenn man so eine Rolle ist sollte man doch darum will zum is Leute haben die die Begriffe da richtig formuliert bekommen.
Letzten Endes hatte ich zu den Eindruck zu müssen dem Teil den ich gesehen habe dass sie ihn eigentlich nicht so richtig eingekreist haben nah darf ich das auch von Senator zu dir Senator ging und mal zwischen Demokraten Republikaner Hin und Her hat er das jetzt auch nicht so eine einheitliche Strategie.
War alles ein bisschen verstörend.
Es gab einen der hat halt irgendwie in eigentlich ganz gut gestellt weil er meinte so ja wenn wir uns hin.
Thai Musik in welchem Hotel sie gestern übernachtet haben kurze Pause.
Nein nicht hier in der Öffentlichkeit und so und dann soll glatt vergessen und Ben und noch eine zweite Sache auch noch dieselbe Richtung ging hinterher dir im Aufzug aber gesund nee sage ich nicht so ne das hat irgendwie in dem Moment sehr schön klargemacht wo,
weil ich das Problem ist ne was ist sitze jemand und sitzt quasi auf dem dem Wissen über alle,
aber ist noch nicht mal der Lage dazu sagen in welchem Hotel er übernachtet hat ich meine wo wo ist jetzt das Problem ne.
Hat er nicht auch die die angrenzenden Grundstücke zusammen gekauft einfach nur damit der keine Nachbarn hat die in der Bude gucken können.
Da das ja ja.
Der Mann der kennt sich aus wenn einer sich mit Privatsphäre auskennt ganz ehrlich dann ist das noch aktuell Werk.
Na gut Moser die Aussagen so eine Person des öffentlichen Lebens hat er sich ganz andere Parameter als unser eins aber trotz alledem bleibt da wie man so schön sagt ein Geschmäckle,
also so richtig viel bei rausgekommen finde ich ist an dich.
Das war ja auch klar sich meine lange in ein langes Lied von Entschuldigung Entschuldigung Entschuldigung das darf nicht mehr passieren gesungen.
Und im Prinzip gibt's keine.
Keine nennenswerten konkreten Versprechungen keine nennenswerten konkreten Änderung des bleibt bei dem Geschäftsmodell so wie es immer ist also werde dir überlegst du dir die der ist ein Skandal verläuft so dass ich am Ende nichts Entscheidendes.
Großartiges ändert da wird dann mal jemand gefeuert,
da wird er mal jemand bei VW Wetter mal jemand angeknackstes oder sowas ne aber die haben jetzt nicht gesagt okay wie weit reicht das mit den mit den Autos mit den Verbrennungsmotoren war eine scheiß Idee wenn man es jetzt anders so.
Das, eine halbherzige Nachrüstung nach der anderen aber das.
So so funktioniert das eben bei den Zug bei den so großen Skandalen wo so viel Geld dranhängt dass man daneben sagt alles klar jetzt müssen wir das mal irgendwie medial hier kurz durchstehen.
Was sollen die also die werden halten nichts fundamental ändern.
Kannst du Versand war ist einerseits dass er halt so tatsächlich auch so eine persönliche Verantwortung von vorne rein zugegeben hat außerdem gab's.
Gabs.
Dann gabs Alex auch diverse Wortwechsel rund um potentielle zukünftige Regulierung und der meinte halt so da wäre dann durchaus offen dafür ne Adresse hat wird auch berichtet das halt so die Lobbygruppe die Facebook sich da,
bezahlt unterhält oder die aufer Senat und Kongress und was passiert wen noch alles,
Reimwörter in Washington dass die also durchaus voll gegen jegliche Regulierung schieß von daher.
Kann man das glauben, dass nicht glauben.
Das verschenkt ich finde das hier alleinsein witzig.
Dass der sich dass er sagt er wäre er aufgeschlossen was what the f*** das ist der Staat sitzt noch wenn der Staat sagt das wird jetzt hier reguliert dann wird das oder wird er kann der sollte überhaupt nicht gefragt werden.
So ne das wird das Team das jetzt irgendwie zu zu zu gut gelegt wird dass er sagt die Hase könnte sich der unter Umständen ein oder andere Regulierung durchaus vorstellen.
Ja schön und gut ab einer marktbeherrschenden Stellung hat Regulierung häufig auch einfach nur noch den den ganz netten Nebeneffekt dass man sich jegliche Konkurrenz vom Leib halten.
Genau dass das ist.
Rhetorischen Anforderung nicht erfüllen.
Das ist hier definitiv ein Faktor und auch so dieses ganze wir schließen jetzt mal die API sind jetzt haben die ganze Zeit Party App haben keinen Zugriff mehr das Kratzen halt jetzt auch am Arsch weil facebook hat seine Position die es hatte ist jetzt auf diese ganzen Apps überhaupt nicht angewiesen,
wichtig ist dass er,
seine Daten in seinem Unternehmen hält und quasi meistbietend den den den Zugriff auf bestimmte Daten Konstellation verkauft aber die Daten selber sind ja einig denn mittlerweile das Gold in der Schatulle da.
Hatten sie mal eine andere Strategie die hat nicht so gut funktioniert rein businessmäßig hat die schon nicht gut funktioniert und jetzt mit dem Skandal mit Cambridge analytica hat das natürlich noch mal.
Extra Krönung bekommen bloß dass es ja nicht.
Die Linie die die Fahne und man merkt es immer wieder in dieser öffentlichen Diskussion und das kam auch tatsächlich noch mal von irgendeinem Senator das so dieser Mythos Facebook würde ja die Daten verkaufen.
Die verkaufen nicht die Daten die verkaufen.
Die verkaufen Wege Zugangswege zu den Leuten auf Basis dieser Daten aber die Daten selber dann die gar kein Interesse daran dass das.
ThyssenKrupp verkauft Stahlwerke so nein Stahl.
Genau ja was war noch dann gab es aber doch nur Lied Neuigkeiten um cambridge.
Analytica dem Zusammenhang da wird ja weiter gegraben werden ja zuletzt schon die Einräumung das von den ursprünglich 50 Millionen Leuten auf einmal 87 Millionen gewesen sein die halt.
Im Bezug auf genau diese eine App diese this is your little live App sozusagen potenziell an Freundes Freunden erreicht wurden was er die API damals als Zugang ermöglicht hat das man eben Freunde von von diesen Leuten auch,
ist noch mit auslesen kann die daran teilnehmen mittlerweile gibt es aber auch noch eine Aussage von.
Alle ehemaligen Mitarbeiterin von Cambridge analytica ich weiß gerade nicht genau welche Rolle sie hatte ich glaube es ja so eine relativ führende Rolle damit nicht so ganz sicher ob sie auch die Chefin war für eine Zeit lang Brittany Kaiser.
Und die berichtet halt so naja also es gab halt noch sehr viel mehr.
Solche Apps dieses System IV live war halt nur eine.
Aber es klappt dann irgendwie bis Spielchen Sex Kompass Pipapo halt immer so diese Dinger mit gib deine Daten ein und wir rechne dreimal durch und erzähl mir was du für ein toller Hengst bist.
Wo dann alle irgendwie auch geil,
mitmachen oder halt auf dieser selben Basis einfach immer noch mehr Freundesfreunde ausgeliefert haben sodass man wohl davon ausgehen kann.
Das die potenziell ausspioniert Profile und das sagt ja Facebook so auch schon so naja also.
Ich werde ich würde mich überhaupt nicht wundern wenn ein Großteil der User dort irgendwo gelandet ist bist ein großer der User der westlichen Welt.
Ja dann zu Rolle von Facebook schöne Meldung wie viel hat denn eigentlich so die Bundesregierung in Facebook Werbung ausgegeben sich noch echt gut in der Zeit von Oktober bis Dezember 2017.
Das war die geschäftsführende Bundesregierung Vagina nach der missglückten Wahl und während der nicht sinnvoll stattfindenden regierungsfindung.
670000 € brutto brutto für das Bewerben eigener Post bei Facebook.
Bin ich echt geil dass das also kann man da nicht kann man das allerletzte unglaublich am meisten Geld in Facebook anzeigen hat das Bundesverteidigungsministerium investiert zwischen Dezember 2013 und Februar 20 Uhr 18 Uhr.
Hat das Bundesverteidigungsministerium insgesamt 3,34 Millionen Euro ausgegeben bei Facebook für irgendwelche Werbung.
Innerhalb von ja in dem Fall jetzt 45 Jahren.
Das finde ich ordentlich und nicht akzeptabel ehrlich gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau in welchem Verhältnis das zu sonstigen Werbemaßnahmen steht mein Bundeswehr und so die machen ja auch Plakatwerbung das ist ja auch nicht ganz billig.
Fernsehwerbung auch also das jetzt in Relation zu setzen ist da habe ich schwierig ob.
Ob das jetzt zurzeit generell gerechtfertigt ist da muss man dann eben auch mal die potenziellen Reichweiten vergleichen die das her hat.
Bitte immer wieder absurd na dass man ja sich hier quasi die Reichweite.
Auch dann erkaufen muss wenn die Leute einem Jahr eine schon folgen wollen ne das denn diese Informationen vorenthalten werden nur wenn man Geld zahlt kann man das eben auch voll ausnutzen.
Das fand ich schon immer so ein bisschen strange an Facebook um nichts kann alles zu sagen.
Ja Tatsache ist da fließt viel Geld rein.
Ich finde das ja also ich,
mich würde auf jeden Fall noch mal interessieren was hat die Bundesregierung denn so für für Anzeigen geschaltet der Verteidigungsministerium ist klar die machen irgendwie hier ballaballa,
Ute sauer kommst zum Boden kannste Haken kannst du Trecker fahren oder LKW fahren oder so ne,
und sagen halt nicht dass du das dann in Afghanistan machen muss oder so aber da ist ja noch irgendwie.
Verstanden oder nachvollziehbar was die machen wofür die Bundesregierung auf Facebook wirbt,
finde ich dann auch ganz an finde ich ganz interessant ne also wenn im Prinzip ja einerseits sagen wir geben Steuer steuern im Wert von Millionen aus um auf Facebook irgendwie zu werben als Bundesregierung und dann aber sagen ob du du du,
Cambridge analytica hier gar nicht gut,
was sind wo ist denn da noch der Unterschied also den erst den erkenne ich wirklich nur marginalen sorry vielleicht bin ich da ein bisschen zu ignorant chemische Analytik hat das ganze Zeit in die günstiger ermöglicht bei Facebook in die Daten.
Er möglich hat raus zu saugen.
Na gut ich meine was ich alles viel interessanter finde ist auf welcher Basis für den hier eigentlich Werbung gemacht meine wenn du sowas wie Plakatwerbung machst,
na dann erreichst du halt deine breit gestreute Öffentlichkeit,
aber ist denn hier die Facebook Werbung auf auf Basis welcher Profile ist denn hier das veröffentlicht worden also.
Eso Tank Anzeigen die jeder sieht,
ist das für jeden deutschen oder hat etwa die Bundesregierung hier gezielt auch Informationen in bestimmte Kanäle mit bestimmten Profilen geschickt weil so funktioniert das ja wenn man da.
Seine Informationen verbreiten möchte die Information steht natürlich hier nicht dabei.
Na ja also ich will jetzt so auf Zahlen und so Millionen klingt immer viel aber muss es natürlich am Ende auch in Relation setzen.
Die Relation haben wir noch nicht haben wir nicht könnt ihr in den Kommentaren und geben dann müssen wir das nicht raussuchen.
Genau.
Die EU würde sich natürlich auch gerne jetzt noch mal mit dem Zuckerberg auseinandersetzen.
Und sind auch mal kurz sich das anhören er hat sich ja entschuldigt und der sagt wa yoru wa.
Ist ja schön wenn Herr Zuckerberg über den Schaden redet der eins der Nutzer entstanden ist über den Schaden für die Gesellschaft und die demokratische Debatte hat er nichts gesagt.
Und sie sagt nötig sei eine schlaue Regulierung die die Risiken herausfiltert und die Internet Sphäre ansonsten nicht weiter beeinträchtigt tja das ist richtig das wäre das was wir brauchen.
Wir wünschen ihr viel Glück auf dem Weg das zu finden und dann auch durchsetzen zu können,
sie denkt auf jeden Fall auch darüber nach Algorithmen die sie für die wichtigsten Instrumente dieser Plattform hält zu regulieren denn diese Algorithmen greifen immer Griffin immer stärker in unser Leben ein,
und,
sind Anlass zur Sorge das sind erstmal natürlich ja wenig konkrete aber immerhin in die richtige Richtung weisen Worte der.
EU-Kommissarin für Justiz Verbraucherschutz und Gleichstellung.
Wo ist auch eine der Kommissarinnen die ich bei meinem Besuch in Brüssel persönlich getroffen habe und so für 15 Minuten im gemeinsamen Gespräch hat oder eine halbe Stunde,
die scheint mir scheint durchaus pro datenschutzgrundverordnung zu sein die macht eigentlich ein ganz ordentlichen Eindruck.
Was wir auch pro datenschutz-grundverordnung ist.
Weiß nicht.
Ja Facebook hat ganz als ich irgendwie die Zeit um zu tapeziert OHL wie schön dass ich zieht datenschutz-grundverordnung kommt,
und das ist ja deine Göttin noch sicher bei Facebook sein müsst ihr noch weniger Angst haben eure Daten bei uns einzugeben.
Und es wird ja auch einige Änderungen geben fällt mir einen es gab doch dieses schöne Foto auf dem der Sprechzeit von Marcus von Marcus von Mark Zuckerberg zu sehen war.
Bitte Dinner bei der Senatsanhörung da vor sich liegen hat aber irgendwie drauf stand er soll bloß nicht sagen sie werden schon dsgvo compliant.
Aber was etwas ändert Facebook also werden jetzt irgendwie.
Eltern von Nutzern im Alter unter 16 Jahren also zwischen 13 14 15 Jahren mit entscheiden lassen.
Ob die Teenager in dem Netzwerkinformationen die Religionszugehörigkeit oder politische Ansichten preisgeben.
Jetzt frage ich mich ob das wirklich heißt preisgeben dass du das dann eben nicht sagen kannst ich bin katholisch oder ob das heißt dass diese Werte.
Anderen angezeigt werden das ist nämlich hier wird als zweiter Faktor genannt die Eltern werden absegnen können,
ob die Jugendlichen personalisierte Werbung auf Basis von Daten anderer Unternehmen angezeigt bekommen und ob sie angeben an Personen welchen Geschlechts Sie interessiert sind also scheint ebenso dass deine Eltern dir das dann verbieten können oder so.
Außerdem können die Nutzerinnen auswählen,
Daten von Partnern für das Zuschneiden von Werbung genutzt werden dürfen damit sind,
Daten gemeint die Facebook über seine Like-Button oder Tracking Pixel auf Drittseiten sammelt also das ist ja auch schon wieder so komplex na da wären wieder solche,
so schöne Worte für finden das keine Sau die da ja oder nein antwortet wirklich weiß was das bedeutet ne.
Micro targeting kann man aber nicht ausschalten das ist ja eigentlich das was wir.
Kritisieren insbesondere nicht mithilfe der custom audiences Funktion wo nämlich Werbetreibende ihre Kundenlisten bei Facebook hochladen können umso die Person auf der Plattform ausfindig zu machen die sie bereits kennen.
Und dann habe ich gedacht wenn wir doch eh so viel umstellen müssen die Leute einmal nerven müssen mit Daten mit Datenschutz Kram und Einwilligung und so weiter na dann schmeißen wir doch direkt noch alles mit auf einen Haufen.
Und führen die Gesichtserkennung wieder ein.
Die hatten sie 2011 schon mal freigeschaltet haben da aber Ärger mit den Datenschützern in ganz Europa bekommen und haben die Funktion wieder ausgeschaltet und sich 2012 im Herbst verpflichtet auch die erzeugten Daten wieder zu löschen.
Das.
Also diese Gesichtserkennung ist quasi das jemand wenn man wenn man fest wenn man bei Facebook ein Bild hochlädt das Facebook automatisch erkennt das ist hier XY.
Und dann wenn wir dann auf das Gesicht klickt dann, nur zu dem Profil oder so und da sagen sie ja.
Das für Räume dann direkt auch noch mal wieder aus und dann wird sehr schön gemacht wird sehr schön unmöglich gemacht das nicht zu machen also.
Erstmal sagen sie der Fisch das ist ja total toll mal hier auf den großen dicken Backen dass du das haben willst ne wenn du dann.
Der Debatten ich möchte das nicht haben ist naturgemäß sehr viel kleiner weil der Bart nicht möchte das haben so groß ist dass man das nicht mehr so viel Platz ist ne deswegen muss der kleiner sein und.
Wird dicker blauer button.
Wenn du nicht zustimmt willst musst du die in Ägypten nicht die Funken nicht einfach einen Knopf do not accepted genauso groß ist sondern es gibt in ganz kleinen manage data settings und da kommst du dann einfach in so einen Wust aus data settings.
Und,
dann wird aber gesagt ja warte mal bist du wirklich sicher also das ist ja gut wenn du das hast weil da damit kannst du missbraucht deines Accounts vor,
vorbeugen wenn also z.b. jemand dein Bild benutzt um einen zweiten Account aufzumachen dann wirst du gewarnt und,
das doch sicherer für dich ne und außerdem hast du dann auch die Kontrolle was andere über dich veröffentlichen das heißt du hast ja im Prinzip so ein Datenschutz Hebel um zu kontrollieren was andere hochladen sonst bieten wir diesen diesen schönen Dienst nicht an,
dich zu warnen oder dich zu dich zu beglückwünschen wenn jemand dein Bild irgendwo hochgeladen hat und dann.
Müssen sich durchaus ein ganz interessantes Feature zu dazu sagen.
Das ist tatsächlich das ist tatsächlich ein Feature und dann kriegst du noch mal zwei Optionen angeboten.
Die obere ist ich erlaube Facebook mich in Fotos erkennen die untere ist das was nicht erlaubt.
Diese unsere muss man dann halt aussehen das heißt.
Um das einzuschalten braucht ein Klick um das dauerhaft zu deaktivieren sind 3 Klicks und 5 mal bist du sicher und hier und mach das doch doch mal ne also es ist auch wieder.
Warum will man das deaktivieren.
Ganz einfach um diese Gesichtserkennung durchzuführen macht Facebook liegt ein sogenanntes Template an mit anderen Worten ein biometrisches eine biometrische.
Erfassung deines Gesichtes.
HDR DC-DC nein also möglich bei neuen Gesichtern zu vermessen zu gucken alles klar was scheint das für ein Gesicht zu sein und dann haben sie ein paar Gesichter in der Datenbank und Gesichtserkennung ist tatsächlich noch nicht so.
Noch nicht so super dass du einen one-to-many Abgleich so gut hinbekommst das heißt sie werden noch weitere Faktoren hinzufügen also das was ich Ort des Bildes und so weiter und dann um quasi noch mal so ein paar Ähnlichkeiten auf der Welt aus zu.
Er auszuschließen aber dann haben Sie also ein,
ein quasi ein Modell deines Gesichts in ihrer Datenbank dass sie eben auch anwenden.
Um dich zu erkennen ich weiß nicht ob man sowas haben möchte das auf jeden Fall die besten besseres Modell eures Gesicht was ihr im Moment dem Staat geben müsst wenn ihr ein biometrisches Foto finden,
Pass oder Personalausweis abgeht also da sind sie auf jeden Fall schon sehr viel besser dann.
Sehr viel tiefgreifender wenn ihr das deaktiviert wenn ich es ausschaltet und deaktiviert löscht Facebook immerhin auf dieses Tablet.
Haben uns gelobt keines für euch anzulegen.
Der ganzen anderen jetzt über wie die Benutzerführung ist ist jetzt deine Vermutung oder da hast du schon konkrete Anhaltspunkte dass es genauso aussieht.
Setze mich auf einen Bericht vom großen Patrick Beuth.
Oder ist er hatte den gezittert nee is ist ein dpa dpa also ist bei bei bei Spiegel Online verlinkt und unter Bezug auf dpa veröffentlicht.
Und auch bei uns in den Charts ansonsten.
Facebook bekräftigt ja und die tolle dsgvo wird ja.
Na die die ganze Welt verbessern weil wir diesen tollen neuen Standard jetzt einfach weltweit ausrollen werden.
Und da dachte man sich ja toll Manchester mit der dsgvo jetzt mal was erreicht worden und das ist doch das ist doch mal schön haben wir mal was erreicht also haben wir mal quasi.
So eine Wirkmacht in die Waagschale geworfen das hier weltweiter Wandel entsteht aber da gibt's dann heute eine Meldung von Reuters heute an,
19. April dass Facebook sich darum bemüht 1,5 Milliarden Milliarden NutzerInnen.
Aus dem Einflussbereich des EU,
Privatsphäre Gesetz ist zu zerren das heißt sie sie nehmen 70% ihrer Nutzer und ziehen die irgendwohin um damit sie nicht mehr bei dieser.
Bei diesem bei diesen Briefkasten in Irland gemeldet sind sondern wieder angenehmer Regulierung unterliegen.
Tja das heißt es gibt durchaus noch Bedarf auch für andere Wirtschafts Räumen ähnliche Regulierung zu erzielen.
Also das ist jetzt genau das ist der Exklusivmeldung von Reuters wovon Plan berichtet wird mal schauen ob Facebook das tatsächlich so durchzieht oder nicht aber der Artikel ist sie auf jeden Fall schon mal wohl informiert.
Gutschein mir mal zurück nach.
Deutschland da läuft ja auch alles super wir hatten ja hier neulich unsere Berichterstattung von dem tollen PA-System dem ganz besonderen anwaltspostfach.
Dem besonderen elektronischen unten.
Die Rechtsanwaltschaft hat's nicht leicht in Deutschland gab nämlich dann noch einen rechtsanwaltsregister.
Das ist wohl auch irgendwie Teil dieses Gesamtsystems ist ein reines Verzeichnis oder was ist das.
Das ist so ein Verzeichnisdienst läuft auf derselben Domain wie das Besondere anwaltspostfach Bea Bea wurde ja jetzt schon abgeschaltet die haben das ja mit mit MD hier aus zu genüge besprochen.
Und das Anwaltsregister wurde aber nach wenigen Tagen schon wieder aktiviert und das hat sich.
Der hanno Böck.
Mal angeschaut und auch ein unabhängige IP Security Unternehmen und da ist eine Sicherheitslücke in einer Java Komponente mit dem Namen primefaces und.
Der Grete er Einblick in den Quelltext hat also schon verraten dass diese Softwarekomponente genutzt wird.
Da wurde wie gesagt 2016 eine Sicherheitslücke entdeckt die es Angreifern erlaubt auf dem Server Java Code auszuführen.
Und diese veraltete Java Komponente war da im Betrieb und.
Jetzt wurde dass das rechtsanwaltsregister infolgedessen auch noch mal kurzfristig abgeschaltet weil es diese diese Schwachstelle hatte.
Die es ermöglicht dadrauf auszuführen und.
Dann ging es wieder an den es wieder an den Start und jetzt wurde noch einen Angriff gefunden,
nämlich ein padding Oracle Angriff den Hallo Böckchen noch mal genauer erklärt der denke ich.
Bitte zu komplex ist als als dass ich unsere Begrenztheit jetzt hier finden würde Ergebnis.
Bleibt das Ding ist halt einfach nur eine einzige Katastrophe mit bekannten Sicherheitslücken seid seit Jahren.
Dort ist läuft aber gerade wieder sich kräftig da mal drauf rum.
Dann haben sie das Update gemacht haben in der Regel auch nicht so schwer mal eben.
Sonne wenn du mal dieses Update zu machen ja na ja also wir sehen diese diese diese dieser dieses Desaster geht einfach weiter.
Timer passieren oder das kommt doch in den besten rechtsanwaltsverzeichnis and where.
Kommt den besten rechtsanwaltsverzeichnis in vor der 2 Jahre alte kritische Sicherheitslücken.
Da waren wir noch.
Ja man muss natürlich was tun.
Und also manchmal ist es ja auch so der lieste solche also das war jetzt auch so eine Meldung die ich während wir angeschaut habe durchgelesen habe und dachte so auch erstaunlich.
Das ist das noch ganz noch nicht gab ja also im Moment.
Würde gerne sicherstellen dass sie bessere Möglichkeit zur Rechtsmittel Durchsetzung hätte also ermittlungsanordnung ja sagen wir es dauert.
Im Moment in die 120 Tage bei einem internationalen Rechtshilfeverfahren sogar zehn Monate wenn man irgendwie Daten bekommen möchte.
Und die europäischen Polizei und Justizbehörden sind damit sehr sind damit sehr unglücklich und das muss alles sehr viel schneller gehen und deswegen gibt es natürlich jetzt einfach mal einen direkten ganz und ordentliches.
Neues Anti-Terror Paket ich weiß garnicht wie viele Anti-Terror-Paket wir schon hatten.
Wieder überhaupt noch Terror übrig geblieben sein konnte.
Ja
Da fragt man sich wieso eigentlich übriggeblieben vielleicht hat das garnichts mit der Klaus zu tun sondern damit zu tun wie sehr uns im internationalen Konflikt Gebaren aber zum Glück ist das welche nicht Logbuch internationaler Konflikt sind nur Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Also sie sie möchten elektronische Beweismittel bei Provider in einfacher und länger sicherstellen können.
Das heißt wir haben ja wenn wir von einem gängigen Provider ausgehen nehmen wir mal Facebook oder irgendein E-Mail-Provider oder was auch immer ein Cloud Provider.
Wir haben ja dann die Bestandsdaten.
Na Name Anschrift Zugangskennung Passwörter für E-Mails SMS und Chat Nachrichten und das sind aber.
Bei den bei den Chat Nachricht ist ja dann schon die Frage ob das nicht er eigentlich Verkehrs oder Inhaltsdaten sind Verkehrsdaten Inhaltsdaten Bestandsdaten doch eigentlich alles haben einschließlich Fotos oder Videos in der Cloud.
Und da soll es also jetzt die.
Europäische Vorlage Anordnung geben wo man dann sagt also unabhängig vom Standort der jeweiligen Daten unmittelbar bei der Dienste anbieten anfordern kann er sagt hallo die haben eine Vorlage Anordnung das wird einmal alles bekommen.
Und zwar ist es hier die Frist regulär 10 Tage.
In Notfällen kann die Frist aber auch auf sechs Stunden verkürzt werden.
Hallo hier ist die europäische Vorlage Anordnung bitte einmal alles zu diesen Nutzer vielen Dank.
Und das ist exakt das was wir es dreht sich alles im Kreis also ich hätte auch alt die das ist National Security letter.
Das was wir mit Nick Merrill beim,
27.03 hatte er dann darüber berichtet das waren im Prinzip diese Anordnung bitte einmal alles und du darfst mit niemand drüber reden aber immer noch der Skandal man durfte auch keine.
Keine keine kein Widerspruch einlegen oder Rechtsmittel oder rechts Hilfe in Anspruch nehmen sondern muss es einfach nur tun.
Ja da ist wieder unsere wäre Eurovan die sagt damit wären die Zugriffszeiten auf die Daten deutlich beschleunigt ja das stimmt sechs Stunden.
Ist echt eine Revolution bei der justiziellen Zusammenarbeit hat die wäre durchaus recht außerdem ich hatte ja gesagt sie wollen nicht nur schnell darauf zugreifen sondern sie wollen auch eine verwahrungs Anordnung haben.
Das heißt der Wirt,
das löschen verhindert na also du hast Daten in der Cloud und du merkst ihn sie sie sie haben dich im Blick ja und dann sagst du auch schnell alles,
löschen wenn du Pech hast haben sie aber schon die verwahrungs Anordnung rausgegeben die natürlich der niederschwellig ist wo sie einfach sagen hier einmal wenn der will wenn die Nutzerin hier irgendwas löschen möchte bitte nicht tun.
Von rechtschaffen.
Mir war überhaupt nicht klar dass das die EU-Kommission überhaupt dann so einem Paket arbeitet und war das irgendwie war das schon absehbar hast du das vorher schon mal was von gehört.
Also ich muss sagen dass ich streckenweise auf der öfter gefragt wie ich die ganzen Sachen im Blick behalten.
Streckenweise behalte ich die auch,
gerade EU Sachen nicht unbedingt im Blick sondern die kommen dann halt zu mir weil sie mir von Freunden die in dem Bereich tätig oder aktiv sind,
oder dann besseres Auge drauf haben angespült werden aber hier klingt es mir auch nach so einer ersten Bekanntgabe eines Gesetzentwurfs ja.
Wichtig ist noch beide Instrumente sind wie das immer so ist zunächst nur für Strafverfahren zugesehen vorgesehen das heißt das wird erst dann im in im dritten oder vierten Nachfolge Anti-Terror-Paket ausgeweitet auf.
Alltagskriminalität und soll daneben für alle Anbieter gelten die ihren Sitz in einem.
Drittland haben ihre Dienst aber auch in der EU zur Verfügung stellen das heißt.
Datum das sicherzustellen müssen sie dann eben einen gesetzlichen Vertreter in der Gemeinschaft benennen ehrlich wir es jetzt bei Facebook der Fall ist ne und dieser,
gesetzliche Vertreter soll dann für die Einhaltung und Vollstreckung von Beschlüssen und Anordnung der zuständigen Behörden der Mitgliedstaaten verantwortlich sein.
Das ist aber nur der erste Teil so jetzt jetzt liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer wisst ihr warum ich sage kauft euch eigene Festplatten betreibt eigene Infrastruktur und in Wien.
Wenn er nicht die absolute security Crack seit hängt sie am besten einfach nicht ans Internet dran das ist irgendwie dann doch noch der einer der.
Besseren Wege sich zu größeren Risikos.
Hör auf dem aus dem Weg zu ziehen ja das wird irgendwann noch mal strafbar werden dass man seine eigenen Datenspeicher vorhält aber solange ihr das noch tun könnt solange die noch frei verkäuflich sind.
Tut das schafft euch die an.
Aber das ist natürlich noch nicht alles hier bei diesem schönen neuen Anti-Terror-Paket denn man braucht natürlich zentrale Register.
Für Finanzinformationen zur Bekämpfung schwerer Straftaten und zur Bekämpfung des Terrorismus klarer Fall.
Und darauf sollen dann zurück bekommen die Ermittler und die Vermögensabschöpfung stell,
ich glaube da meinen Sie die Zoll und Steuern oder was ne die sollen also schnell Zugriff auf Kontodaten bekommen auch das natürlich hier schön euer Opa weit und so weiter und nur bei schweren Straftaten sie wissen schon.
Das ein schönes Wort eine Vermögensabschöpfung Städte.
Verbinde ich meinen werde ich meinen buchhaltungsordner nennen.
Was bedeutet der Begriff Geld beschlagnahmen du komplett neu Konnotation.
Wie nehme ich ab jetzt mein Konto bitte überweisen Sie den Betrag X von fünf Städte mit der Nummer.
Genau dann bitte hier im Vermögen effizient abschöpfen kann.
Welche Sprache hat schon den einen oder anderen schönen.
Euphemistische Neologismus für uns parat da können wir uns auch freuen.
Na ja aber machen wir weiter ist damit wäre der Terror ja noch nicht ausreichen eingedämmt es wäre ja nur zentrale Finanz Überwachung und und Vollzugriff auf alle Cloud Daten was fehlt.
Biometrie.
Natürlich bislang haben wir in Deutschland nur die verpflichtende Abgabe von biometrischen Merkmalen.
Im Reisepass bzw stimmt nicht also.
Biometrisches Foto braucht man für den neuen Personalausweis und das wird digital gespeichert Fingerabdrücke.
Sind freiwillig im.
Die Person im Reisepass müssen die auch seit 2007 verpflichten gespeichert werden das heißt es entsteht hier natürlich eine Schutzlücke,
Personalausweis Inhaber deswegen bitteschön sehr schnell Fingerabdrücke und weitere biometrische Daten müssen dann sollen laut EU-Verordnung dann in Personalausweise mit aufgenommen werden müssen.
Zum Zwecke welcher Zweck wird hier angeführt Fälschungssicherheit der Papiere erhöhen damit die Kommission.
Nicht konforme Ausweise relativ rasch auslaufen lassen der auslaufen können.
Zur Ablauf ihrer Gültigkeit oder aber spätestens innerhalb von fünf Jahren das heißt die verkaufen dir so ein Personalausweis die verkaufen die auch nicht meine dass wir sowieso die Schärfe zum Perso Kosten habe ich 35 € oder so musst du bezahlen.
Ist aber nicht deiner.
Bist du gemietet.
Deckblatt gehört die hin mit anderen Worten du du sagst dann jetzt hier 35 € wenn irgendein gestanden ist Alters ist der Glaube 10 Jahre gültig und dann geht Dir nur sagen verkürzen ja auch noch die Laufzeit davon.
Ja das heißt du kriegst du Zeit quasi dann pro Jahr doppelt eine nachträgliche gebührenerhöhung,
für die Gesamtlaufzeit Miete eines solchen Ausweises denke da werde ich mich gegen zur Wehr setzen und natürlich sofort,
erstinstanzlich und letztinstanzlich mit einem lauten Lachen scheitern aber ich find's trotzdem nicht in Ordnung ich brauche das an.
Trotzdem werde ich natürlich jetzt bemüht sein mir noch schnell ein Perso zu sichern für den ich keine Fingerabdrücke abgeben muss.
Und die Ankündigung ist in zwei Jahren soll es dann doch bitteschön keine.
Papier Ausweisdokumente mehr geben nur noch neue und fälschungssicherer und kluge und smarte Ausweise mit biometrischen Daten und Fingerabdrücke.
Peter Schaar kommentiert dazu also der ehemalige der letzte tätige Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte den wir in Deutschland hatten.
Also danach wurde das ja noch wurde die Position ja von.
Oder Frau deren Namen man nicht mehr erinnert verwaltet vom Fass auf keiner.
Also besetzt im Sinne von navi Flora ist besetzt,
was hattest du würdest Datenschutzstelle besetzt und niemand ran.
Er schreibt dazu während die Pässe in den die Fingerabdrücke brideshead 2008 torisch gespeichert werden nur auf Antrag ausgestellt und für bestimmt Reisen in bestimmte Länder außerhalb der in Union benötigt werden.
Sind die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in den meisten EU-Mitgliedstaaten verpflichtet sich verpflichtet sich ein Personalausweis ausstellen zu lassen,
und diesen bei Kontrollen etwa bei EU bin und Außengrenzen vorzulegen das neue Form hat deshalb eine ganz andere Breitenwirkung als die Einführung der biometrischen Merkmale,
bei EU Reisepässen vor 10 Jahren genau du musst nämlich,
dir diesen Personalausweis holen wenn du irgendwie das Land verlässt bis verpflichtet den vorzuweisen und eben der Besitz eines.
Personalausweis ist nicht optional mit anderen Worten innerhalb kürzester Zeit haben wir dann eben auch hier das vollständige biometrische.
Register jetzt müsste ich noch mal schauen wir hatten jetzt zuletzt dieses EAT Gesetz.
Bei dem sowieso der Zentrale zu gefragt die biometrischen Daten geregelt war dann da müsste ich jetzt noch mal reinschauen hat mir eine Stellungnahme zu geschrieben.
Der CCC ich glaube Constanze Kurz Starbuck und ich bin da dran stehen wenn ich mich nicht täusche ist noch mal schauen.
Da müsste ich jetzt noch mal genau in den Gesetzestext schauen ob dann nicht sofort die Fingerabdrücke damit gelten das weiß ich gerade nicht das hätte ich habe ich versäumt im Namen der im Rahmen der Sendung Zubereitung mir anzuschauen.
Müssen wir nachliefern oder bieten euch das doch mal in den Kommentaren kurz nachzuliefern ihr könnt ja auch mal was recherchieren.
Ich habe auch noch eine Frage wo werden denn diese Fingerabdrücke gespeichert eigentlich.
Das ist genau der also eigentlich auf den Druck auf den Ausweisdokumenten.
Deshalb habe ich gerade Bezug zu diesem neuen e-id gesetzt Woge also diese.
Die Speicherung der Daten wurde ja nach und nach aufgeweicht also als die Pässe eingeführt wurden wurde gesagt wir speichern das wird erstmal nur auf dem Pass und wir löschen es nachher wieder.
Und dann wurden aber diese Datenbanken erstellt und dann wurde er zentrale Zugriff darauf geregelt und so weiter und so weiter und so weiter deswegen weiß ich nicht wie im Moment laut e-id Gesetz.
Ob das bedeuten würde dass die Fingerabdrücke auch in einer Datenbank landen oder nur auf den Dokument.
Weißt du das ist wieder das Problem mit den Gesetzesentwürfen und den Dips und ich weiß gerade nicht was dieser ein Gesetzesentwurf.
Diese Androhung eines Gesetzesentwurfs einer EU-Verordnung vor dem Hintergrund des e-id Gesetzes bedeuten würde wenn das dann in Deutschland umgesetzt wird in nationales Recht das weiß ich gerade nicht.
Aber im Zweifelsfall nimm das Schlimmste an.
Wärmezentrale Fingerabdruck Datenbank für alle Bundesbürger ausgerollt innerhalb von wenigen Jahren spätestens fünf weil sie ja sagen maximal solange lassen Sie den neuen Ausweis auf dem noch kein Fingerabdruck gespeichert ist.
Immer noch mal nach die fand die.
Nee nee nee das können unsere hörenden nachliefern in den Kommentaren.
Der.
Bitte in die Kommentare es gibt zu gewinnen die Vorlesung eines Kommentar das in der LMP2 151.
Ganz exklusiv das kommt nie wieder.
Könnt auch anrufen.
Das machen irgendwie du hast recht das macht die Leute nicht mehr warum nicht 0301208 803 880 könnte anrufen zu sagen.
Mit dem Bruch egal andere Diskussion.
Ach ja die Diskussion hat noch du hast gewonnen wenn ihr wollt das Team gewinnt ruft mich an.
Der Anrufbeantworter ist jetzt schon mal voll weil wir dich schon gewinnen sehen hat ja wohl am Wochenende gereicht mit Union St. pauli.
Ja ich bin ganz schön populär manchmal ja tut mir leid aber musste sein.
Reden wir nicht drüber Tim haben wir gesagt.
Sag mir mal lieber wäre eigentlich überhaupt noch zuhört.
Also es gibt die Grünen hören zu die sind ja Opposition.
Christoph nie wieder zu hören.
Nadia die dürfen ja schon länger zuhören aber die haben jetzt einen,
haben gesagt okay dann schauen wir uns doch mal an was so alles irgendwie an schief läuft im Staate Dänemark und legen einen Antrag vor mit dem Sicherheit Stärken Freiheit erhalten Frieden sichern.
Und sagen sie wollen bitte dass die Bundesregierung auf sämtliche Maßnahmen gefährdet die die Sicherheit gefährden und sie fordern konkrete Maßnahmen.
Zur Erreichung bessere die Sicherheit ist ein mehrseitiger Antrag erst einmal so alle einmal alle guten Ideen reingeschrieben.
Was ist ein Antrag für den Bundestag zur Entscheidung im Bundestag oder ist es eine innerparteilicher.
Also der Bundestag wolle beschließen da steht aber dann jetzt.
Quasi nur und wenn der Bundestag das verschließt dann vor der Bundestag die Bundesregierung auf folgende Maßnahmen zu ergreifen.
Na also weiß ja mann das ist ein Antrag der der Opposition dass sie,
liegen die zu den Akten der hat ja auch schon eine Drucksache Nummer 19 Schrägstrich 31028 der komplett zu den Akten aber da sind war gar nicht so schlechte Ideen drin.
Unter anderen sagen sie.
Verfassungsrechtliche Gewährleistungspflicht des Staates für die IT Sicherheit mit anderen Worten der Staat darf die Sicherheit seiner Bürger nicht mehr,
gefährden oder auch nur riskieren insbesondere bei der Strafverfolgung der Gefahrenabwehr und Gefahren Beobachtung muss auf die muss auf IP Sicherheit gefährdende Maßnahmen verzichtet werden,
hierzu gehören unter anderem Offensive Operation sogenannte Hatchback Ankauf und offen halten und die Ausnutzung von bislang nicht öffentlich bekannten Sicherheitslücken.
Oder auch die Überlegung einer gesetzlichen Verpflichtung Unternehmen Hintertüren für Hard und Software.
Einzug zu verbauen also im Prinzip einmal alles was als Sicherheit und Vertrauen in Systeme schlecht ist zu unterlassen sagen sie wir wollen natürlich,
Verschlüsselung von Daten Kommunikation stärken E-Government Angebote sind,
beste IP Sicherheitslösung auf dem neuesten Stand der Technik umzusetzen ja das ist wie wir an Bea und.
Brav also den bundesrechtsanwaltsverzeichnis,
auch noch weiteren System die sich in der Zukunft oder vielleicht auch schon in der Gegenwart angeschaut werden der Fall ist das ist halt alles Grütze ist weil da irgendwelche.
Der Zauberlehrling versucht haben das Rad neu zu erfinden.
Ja und wenn Zauberlehrlinge versuchen das Rad neu zu erfinden dann kommt halt ein BA bei raus.
So na sagen sie da gibt's Stand der Technik da gibt's neue Systeme da sollen wir uns dran sollen wir uns bitte dran halten.
Haftung,
wollte Stärken KA das ist ja eine der zentralen Forderungen mit der ich ja seit Jahren hausieren gehen und der Frank und der ganze CCC gerade hinsichtlich der Besonderheiten und riesigen vernetzte IT Systeme müssen bestehende Haftungsregelung überprüft und neue gesetzliche Regelung vorgelegt werden.
Und dann die muss ich natürlich noch vorlesen nachdem wir diesen wunderschönen pc-wahl.
Hektar ausgeheckt haben und uns so viel Mühe gegeben haben ist ja bekanntlich wie immer nichts passiert und da sagen die Grünen dass er doch mal schön wenn,
wir einfach sagen bei Software ist die Veröffentlichung des Quellcodes,
Überprüfbarkeit sicherzustellen Qualität freie und offene Software um die Qualität freie und offene Software zu verbessern ist ein Fall für die Prämierung der Identifizierung Behebung und Bekanntmachung von Fehlern infel offener Software,
Bug Bounty ist also zu schaffen und die Forschungsförderung in dem Bereich zu intensivieren ja alles Forderung meine Güte das habe ich in.
Nicht das tragen wir seit Jahren vor und es wissen auch alle dass das sinnvoll und richtig ist.
Das ist ja nicht so als müsste man als wäre das jetzt noch irgendwie zu argumentative Auseinandersetzung auszusetzen das eine Wahl Software.
Offen zu sein es gibt kein Argument kein haltbares kein tragfähiges Argument dafür wahlsoftware nicht Open Source zu haben und ich erwarte da ohnehin ein.
Eine höchstrichterliche Rechtsprechung zu dem Thema die uns bisher leider nur verwehrt geblieben ist.
Ja so als Minimum ne.
Man Sound schade dass schade dass solche Ideen immer nur von der Opposition kommen ich erkenne da ein Muster.
Welches wohl.
Die Frage ist also man müsste man so einen AB Test machen und gucken ob solche schönen Ideen auch von den Parteien umgesetzt wird wenn sie in eine Regierung sind aber dann wir jetzt bei den Grünen längere Zeit nicht mehr die Gelegenheit gehabt das zu testen.
Mit Einschränkung würde ich sagen.
Er ist Eminem auf Landesebene haben wir ja Regierungsbeteiligung der Grünen aber das wäre doch mal sei doch jetzt mal wirklich da könnte man noch mal wenn ihr jetzt in der.
Vorausgesetzt in der in der Bundesregierung werden so ein paar kluge Köpfe noch vorhanden dann könnte man doch hier mal was Sinnvolles tun vielleicht finden Sie ja bei Doro Berge höher und die sagt.
Flugtaxi nur mit Fell offener Bundestagswahl.
Guck mal da mal was sonst noch für kluge Köpfe in unserer Bundesregierung gibt da gibt's noch ein paar neue oder.
Also mir fällt jetzt keine ein ist auch wirklich keine gute Überleitung zum nächsten Thema kluger Kopf.
Bitte nee ich habe gesagt ein paar neue gibt.
Noch so nein die hat doch neue Gesichter gibt's neue Köpfe.
Neue Köpfe für Minecraft die so sind.
Ja genau neue Köpfe wenn wir mal gucken könnte welches Potenzial die wohl haben.
Herr Spahn.
Der genau der der Gesundheitsminister ist ja jetzt primär erstmal.
Dadurch aufgefallen dass ihm so die seinen Arbeitsbereich.
PDC Zuständigkeitsbereich seines resource nicht zu Beginn ganz klar war.
Ja er hat sich ein alles eingemischt und vor allem schöne plumpe Meinung formuliert und sich dann gefreut dass sich alle darüber aufregen was er von Schluss redet so ist das halt wenn man als Stuss reden hin,
verantwortungsvollen Position ist dann kann man sich freuen dass man wenn man Schluss redet noch mehr Reaktion darauf bekommt.
Hanne lange natürlich immer geschrieben meine Güte kümmer dich um die Gesundheit.
Und haben vielleicht gedacht dann wird es besser jetzt haben wir nur natürlich nicht daran gedacht das was das bedeutet wenn Jens Spahn sich um die Gesundheit kümmert um die Gesundheitspolitik dann hat er nämlich jetzt auf der Messe.
ConhIT also Medizin als die Messe direkt mal einen drei punkten Plan.
Für die Entwicklung der Gesundheitspolitik vorgelegt und damit gesagt sowas also was erzählt er jetzt leider sind IP und Medizin Messe ich glaube in Berlin ist die da sitzen sie da alle mit ihren mit ihren neuen.
Industrie of Pop windansea Robotern und dann sagt er also erstens.
Telemedizin.
Mit Online-Sprechstunde keiner was soll mir zum Arzt das wenn man muss nicht mehr zum Arzt gehen Online-Sprechstunde gibt's ja das Wiedersehen zweitens die Gesundheits medizinische Forschung.
Möge doch bitte mit Big Data stattfinden.
Und zwar mit anonymisierten und pseudonymisierten da.
Jeder alle Kranken sollen eine datenspende beitragen und umso der Gesamtheit zu helfen schwierig ne also es ist.
Es ist natürlich das Argument.
Ist nicht ist auf jeden Fall mal da das unter Umständen medizinische Forschung.
Besser vorangetrieben werden.
Würde könnte wenn je mehr Daten zur Verfügung stehen und das sicherlich in den Patientenakten über Krankheitsverläufe und sonstiges eine ganze Reihe noch zu entdeckenden wissen zu gewinnen wäre.
Ja also.
Da ich gerade im Begriff bin genau zu diesem Thema ein Podcast zu veröffentlichen Berührung mit diesem Thema und ich muss sagen.
Da gehe ich jetzt erstmal grundsätzlich sogar mit bei diesem Forderung.
Ja kann er sagt ja das also ich weiß nicht ob er Spanners gesagt hat aber ich würde das erstmal jetzt nicht so stehen lassen wollen dass Telemedizin in der Online-Sprechstunde eine schlechte Idee ist.
Das Gegenteil ich halte das für wichtig dass dass dass wir dahin kommen dass das möglich ist.
Welchem Rahmen das mit dir selber siehst ja heutzutage lassen Unterversorgung in bestimmten Gebieten ist es generell extrem schwierig Termine zu bekommen beim Arzt,
und viele Leute gehen dann halt auch einfach gar nicht zum Arzt weil sie halt genau diese Probleme schon kennen,
mal ganz abgesehen von dem Zeitaufwand den hast um Arztbesuch zu machen Job die Problematik das,
du nicht ohne weiteres Zeit bekommst oder der sich vielleicht am Ende oder nach Urlaub nehmen musst nur umso sagen ob das mal rauszufinden was mit dir ist weil solange du ja nicht krankgeschrieben bist,
bist du ja nicht krank und,
warum sollte man die Möglichkeiten von Remote Gesprächen und Analysen und 2. nicht nutzen.
Da sehe ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Grund der Zeit ist es aber bei uns richtig in Deutschland so dass es halt einfach untersagt ist.
Sprich hier steht im Prinzip neroform an die einfach mal mit den technischen Möglichkeiten auch mitgehen muss II.
Die Forschung über Big Data.
Und anonymisiert oder pseudonymisiert die Daten hier steckt natürlich der Teufel im Detail aber auch da würde ich sagen.
Da ist wirklich eine Menge Potential ne nicht nur bei jetzt sowas wie.
Forschung wenn jetzt mal was dass ich als wir hier diesen Ebola outbreak hatten und so weiter da ist ja auch extrem schnell dran gearbeitet worden das hatte sehr viel auch mit der elektronischen Aufarbeitung,
Lafette zu tun dass da Bestandssicherung Forschungsergebnisse geteilt wurden etc.pp,
aber auch so generell solchen Forschung ne Grippewellen will man halt schnell bekommen und natürlich uns noch ein bisschen weiter zu denken,
generell ist halt die Diagnostik und die Forschungs Medizin nutzt hier einfach nicht ihr Potenzial,
ja weil das ist natürlich natürlich immer eine sehr datengetriebene Forschung du brauchst halt viele Beobachtung brauchst halt viel,
samples und muss natürlich dann auch in etwa wissen von von wem die kommt das nicht von wem einzelnen die kommt sondern von wem ne Alter Geschlecht.
Bitte der APP und.
Ich finde es okay dass man das anstrebt in welchem Rahmen das dann reduziert wird ne und wie ein Datenschutz jetzt hier garantiert werden soll dass es jetzt sicherlich diskussionswürdig aber mit den Zielen würde ich jetzt erstmal einhergehen.
Sehe ich auch so ich würde nur darauf hinweisen dass dass das ganz herzlich ein desaströses disaster Potenzial hat vor allem wenn das von von irgendwie von solchen.
Laser Gehirn dann irgendwie in in in die Gänge gesetzt wird wie sie BAG Mail,
und uns ne da da da weißt also da wird mir ganz anders ja das ist,
und dann irgendwie so ein Jens Spahn darüber die die die Hoheit hat er in seiner Rede sagt übertriebene Datenschutz Anforderung an bestimmter Stelle dürfen nicht die Versorgung verunmöglichen.
Er will ihr wie die sichere Autobahn für Gesundheitsdaten und jetzt die würde er jetzt gerade hier bauen weil ich weiß nicht was der damit überhaupt meint ja wahrscheinlich irgendwelche VPN Boxen oder sowas.
Wir müssen aber auch noch die Autos bauen und die Industrie möge jetzt in Zukunft eine größere Schnittstellen Öffentlichkeit bereitstellen.
Ich hoffe damit meint er Interoperabilität das also.
Ich meine immer bei neu entstehenden Märkten von ihr was mit Netz,
natürlich jeder Hersteller seine eigenen Standard in der Hoffnung dass ich die anderen irgendwann nach seinem Standard richten müssen und das ist quasi nur so ein so ein so ein Verdrängungswettbewerb man dann am Ende,
das Facebook der Medizintechnik ist oder so ne und dann irgendwie,
oder der Marktführer und dann quasi Lizenz die Zensierung oder sonst was daran mitverdient das andere Interoperabilität mit den eigenen Geräten herstellen können.
Ich vermute dass er mit Schnittstellen Öffentlichkeiten meint dass es deine Standards geben soll in die also finde Interoperabilität Song.
Ja die brauchen wir.
Das werde ich Schnittstellen Öffentlichkeit höre denke ich natürlich an Hex Hex ne dass das Ding sofort offen ist und wir so hier weißt du der der Nachbar hat.
Was weiß ich denn der Nachbar hat Gelbsucht woher weißt du das ja aus habe ich in der Schnittstellen Öffentlichkeit erfahren so ungefähr ne.
Von dem von den Bundesbürgern erwartet span eine neue Bereitschaft zur datenspende.
Und dann siehst ich mit der fetten.
Das große Thema bei der conhIT sind nämlich die elektronische Patientenakte und die elektronischen Patienten Fächer.
Und in der elektronischen Patientenakte sind alle Befunde Diagnosen Therapiemaßnahmen Arztbriefe und mehr über den Patienten gespeichert.
Und das elektronisch patientenfach soll alle Daten speichern die der Patient sehr ist ein einspeis z.b. auch Blutzuckerwerte also du kannst dann kriegt irgendwie,
muss jetzt wissen Blutzucker Überwachung 9 bin immer deine Werte dahin geblasen ja das hat das erleichtert vieles total und auch was Apple da vor Jahren schon mit diesem healthkit finde Vision entwickelt hat da erkennt man.
Große Potenziale.
Zur medizinischen Anwendung aber das muss dann eben auch von Leuten gebaut werden die dazu in der Lage sind das so zu bauen dass diese Daten dann einem Datenschutz der Privatsphäre und IP Sicherheit unterliegen und ich.
Ich bin da mit großer großer Sorge gefüllt wenn sowas in Deutschland gebaut wird.
Ja ich meine ich teile natürlich deine Skepsis was hierzu die konkrete Umsetzung vor allem innerhalb eines deutschen Kontextes macht man das ist ja ein Ding da müsste man eigentlich wirklich jetzt schon global denken gerade im Hinblick darauf dass die besten,
Daten sammel Geräte der Zeit sowieso an den Handgelenken installiert werden die ganzen smartwatches die halt,
in der Lage sind zu nah am Körper wichtige Parameter mit zu erfassen und in zunehmendem Maße auch,
Dinge die man bisher noch nicht gewohnt sind ne also auch bei Diabetikern ist das ja so ein Thema da verbessert sich ja gerade die,
die Technologie um Nutzer mit dem konkreten Problem auf einer täglichen Basis klarzukommen wird da auch immer besser mit so.
Elektronischen Nadeln da drin stecken und die ganze Zeit dein Blutzuckerspiegel messen dann hast du das irgendwie auf deine Uhr und muss halt nicht diese schwierigen Prozesse durchlaufen wie sie noch vor,
wenigen Jahren üblich war oder teilweise heute auch noch sind,
und natürlich würde ich mir auch wünschen dass man da an der Stelle weg findet wie man halt,
offen Arztwechsel jederzeit gut macht ne also die Möglichkeit meine zweite Meinung einzuholen und dann ist das ist natürlich alles sehr datengetrieben und Müller halt sagen kannst ja hier ich halte das mal meine Uhr an deinen Computer,
lieber neuer Arzt so und dann blim blim hast du mal soeben,
3 4 5 Jahre History + Herzschlag der letzten 10 Jahre on screen das natürlich da mit dem man arbeiten kann.
Ganz ganz also auf jeden Fall und ich glaube dass das wird wenn man das sinnvoll umsetzen und baut wird das vielen Menschen leben retten oder Lebensjahre dazu bringen ganz ganz ohne Frage.
Ja bloß werden wenn Sie entspannen datenspende sagt dann kriegt das halt so ein bisschen wie Nierenspende.
Tannhäuser Datum Zoo in Berlin.
Na ja bald Mama im Auge und an der Stelle mit hier auch gleich die nächste Folge vom Forschergeist Platten die sich mit diesem Thema sehr intensiv auseinandersetzen wird sie ganz toll.
Ja aber bleiben wir mal beim beim Speichern von medizinischen Daten ich bin mal gespannt auf dich deine sich da nicht vielleicht jetzt direkt beim nächsten Thema ändert.
Guck Mama.
Bayern steht fest wir schließen irgendwie mehr als keiner mehr als jedes andere Bundesland Menschen gegen ihren Willen in die Psychiatrie.
Nämlich 2015 60000 Menschen 60.000 Menschen in Bayern gegen ihren Willen in die Psychiatrie gekommen.
Ob das jetzt eine oder niedriger Wert ist.
Sagt er erstmal garnichts aus vielleicht hat mir auch einfach exakt 60000 Menschen die genau gegen ihren Willen eine Psychiatrie mussten und die Sorgfaltspflicht des Bundeslandes wurde der gut wahrgenommen Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Hat knapp 48000.
Leute in in die Psychiatrie geschickt gegen ihren Willen aber hat auch 150% der Einwohner also 60000.
In Bayern und ein Fünftel weniger in einem Land was anderthalb mal so groß ist.
Männer sagen sie okay dann müssen wir irgendwie dumm kümmern dann gehst du jetzt ein neues bayerisches psychiatriegesetz sagen sie okay.
Firma wir bauen unseren Krisendienst aus den ganz bisher.
Kannst du eine telefonische Hotline nur in Oberbayern und Mittelfranken haben sie großartige Erfahrung mit gemacht.
Menschen die angerufen haben sagen Ihnen wie topfe Krisenberatung gerne wieder und konnten da vielen Menschen helfen und nass ist ein Angebot was angenommen wurde und was was rund rund um positiv.
Bewertet wird was ich auch wirklich ein sehr wichtiges Angebot finde.
Telemedizin Telemedizin.
Das ist Telefon Indizien ja genau.
Telemedizin ist das.
Und M.
Das ist sehr wichtig für Menschen die sich in akuten Stress Not und seelischen nur Zuständen Befinden des Weges das ja gut dass das aufgebaut wird aber das Geld für die Hand nehmen alles super.
Und dann sagen sie ja aber vielleicht können wir ja auch.
Straftäter mit einer psychiatrischen Diagnose.
Und vielleicht können wir heute mit einer psychiatrischen Diagnose auch präventiv einfach unterbringen wenn sie für sich selbst oder andere zur Gefahr werden.
Können.
Also Menschen die sich dass die drohen sich das Leben zu nehmen andere oder Leute die andere gefährden z.b. in der Schwangerschaft trinken.
Also das wäre dann auch schon Fremdgefährdung von Menschen die aber noch nicht straffällig sind und die sollen dann halt auch festgehalten werden und irgendwie sowas wie.
Wie im Maßregel versuche Maßregelvollzug irgendwie mit Videokamera überwacht werden bei besuchen und so weiter gehen wir schon im wieso ein bisschen in den an die Grenze,
und dann sagen sie mir dann machen wir außerdem machen wir noch eine unterbringungs Datei.
In der persönliche Daten der Patienten vom Namen bis hin zu Diagnose gespeichert werden und für öffentliche Behörden darunter auch die Polizei zugänglich sind.
Das heißt du du du du du kriegst in in Bayern gesicherte Diagnose kommt sofort in die oder.
Kommst du kommst eine psychiatrische Diagnose und wirst vielleicht irgendwie mal ein paar Tage da behalten oder kurierst dich mal ein paar Tage aus indem offen in der offenen oder in der geschlossenen je nachdem.
Was du brauchst du da kommst du in diese kommst du in diese unterbringungs Datei und wenn ich das nächste Mal ihren Polizist anhält und nach deinem Papieren fragt an ascend der und kann einfach sagen ah alles klar.
Der war vor vier Jahren mal wegen wegen einer Depression.
Zwei Wochen auf Ronnys Ranch und dessen verrückt hat erst eine Gefahr für die Allgemeinheit in unterziehen wir jetzt anderen.
Kontrollen also die komplette Verletzung ärztliche Schweigepflicht massives Stigmatisierung der Betroffenen als ich meinen das dauert nun wirklich.
Ja vor allem wenn er nass und präventiv Moment drin ist ne dann wird es noch mal besonders bedrohlich abgesehen davon dass man an der Stelle glaube ich diese Trennung auf gar keinen Fall auflösen sollten da bin ich ganz bei dir.
Ja und da wenn die da jetzt mit ihrer EPA und so weiter ich meine inzwischen kennen wir das Spiel auch wir sind Deutschland läuft ne dann gibt es irgendwann wieder Terror,
Dingens und so und dann wird gesagt na ja okay erstmal machen wir vielleicht nur eine Kennzeichnung ob schon mal jemand in der Psychiatrie war oder so aber du weißt wie es läuft also bisher aber die Erfahrung gemacht leider leider leider das ist sich immer,
jedes einzelne mal als eine schlechte Idee erwiesen hat irgendwie alle Daten auf einen Haufen zu werfen das war einfach immer so.
Und mit Jens Spahn als Gesundheitsminister und Horst Seehofer als Innenminister bin ich da halt skeptisch,
das jetzt unbedingt mit großen Schritten in die zentrale Datenhaltung der Telemedizin marschieren sollen.
Da muss man halt zusehen dass man da wirklich neue Prinzipien von.
Idealfall auch erstmal privater lokaler verschlüsselter Speicherung und dann eben einen gezielten einzelnen Freigabe dieser Informationen an Bedürftige.
Bedürftiges falsches Wort also an die Leute an dem asozialen auch explizit geben möchte dass es so ein so ein bewusster Schritt ist damit wäre ich ja wunderbar dabei aber in dem Moment wo man das ganze Pult und zentral vorhält da müssen wir natürlich,
wie gut die Daten dort nämlich gesichert sind nämlich langfristig weil einfach mal gar nicht da wären wir uns doch nicht wundern dürfen in diese ganzen Psychiatrie Daten irgendwann mal so als Backup auf einfach rumliegen,
das wollen wir natürlich nicht.
Und dann werden sie.
Die haben.
Und weg das kannst du den das kannst du dir sagen wie du willst dann kommt deutsch dann wird Deutschland am Ende sagen ja dann machen wir ne,
der stell mir irgendwo Wurst Sicherheitsserver hin und Bau eine Mauer drum und dann wie findet eine Leine kurze Umschlüsselung statt weißt du so einen Scheiß kommt heute am Ende wieder bei raus.
Mark my words.
Deutsche Mark Joghurt.
Kapitelmarke Joghurts.
Damit wären wir jetzt bei den kurzen.
Wir müssen uns beeilen die Zeit rennt davon wir versuchen es mal hier wirklich kurz sein okay.
Ja
Es gibt zwischen 2013 eine Auseinandersetzung zwischen dem.
New Yorker Bundes Bezirksgericht und Microsoft weil das Gericht Microsoft zwingen möchte,
E-Mails an seiner Kunden auch herauszugeben wenn die auf Servern in im Bereich der EU sind also nicht in der Jurisdiktion.
Und das ist jetzt bis ans höchste Gericht gegangen wo der US Supreme Court dann darüber entscheiden sollte ob die ob die Justiz der USA Microsoft quasi zwingen kann,
diese Daten.
Rauszugeben obwohl sie sich in der Jurisdiktion anderer Länder befindet die Server sich in der Jurisdiktion Anna-Lena befinden Microsoft hat die Ansicht vertreten dass sie dazu nicht verpflichtet sind und der Supreme Court hat jetzt gesagt.
Ich werde nicht mehr urteilen damit.
Hat Microsoft gewonnen weil damit das letzte Urteil in der Sache erstmal Bestand hat.
Und deshalb Microsoft quasi jetzt dauerhaft gewonnen hat was diesem Rechtsstreit angeht aber.
Am 23 März wurde der sogenannte Cloud Act der USA beschlossen in der Feld der legt fest dass Dienste Betreiber Kundendaten herausgeben müssen egal wo die Daten psychisch psychisch tschuldigung physisch gespeichert.
Genauere Daten nicht zu psychisch gespeichert gute Frage.
Man kann dann wieder er wieder Betreiber keinen Widerspruch einlegen und dann und so weiter ne aber nur wenn der Betroffene Kunde ein US-Bürger ist also mit anderen Worten der Drops ist gelutscht das hat die Legislative inzwischen geklärt deswegen braucht er auch der.
Supreme Court nicht mehr sich der Sache anzunehmen dann haben wir am.
Letzte Woche eigentlich sogar versäumt noch darauf hinzuweisen dass es so eine kleine.
Patria patriotischer scheinbar patriotische Router Angriff Serie aus den von US Leuten auf russische Ziele gab die irgendwie sich auf die Cisco Router.
Mit einer Bekannten Schwachstelle rein gedingst haben und dann irgendwie eine Nachricht hinterlassen haben mit ihm so eine ASCII US Fahne wo drin stand hier don't don't mess with Texas oder sowas.
Hört mit dem Cyberkrieg auch wir können auch oder so ne und jetzt kam dann die große Warnung wieder also jetzt ist ja erstaunlich wie letztens auch mit einem Kollegen unterhalten er sagte so unglaublich wie.
Wie bemüht Russland zu sein scheint sich irgendwie am laufenden Band überall irgendwelchen Ärger ein zuhanden jetzt angeblich mit einer.
Cyber Kampagne der das FBI das Department of Homeland Security,
und das nationales Zentrum für cybersicherheit Großbritanniens warnen angeblich würde die würde dieser Kampagne vom russischen Staat finanziert und insbesondere zähle sie auf Netzwerktechnik bei Behörden und Unternehmen ab.
Aber auch auf kritische Infrastruktur und bei auf bei den bei den Anbietern von Internetzugängen und so und die russischen Hacker in also jetzt weltweit im großen Stil Netzwerkinfrastruktur infiltriert.
Erstaunlich dass die jetzt gerade dazu Zeit haben aber so eine Warnung kannst du erstmal nur.
Ernstnehmen BSI sagt dann dazu nachher konkrete Vorfälle in Deutschland bei denen.
Der die das Vorgehen der Angreifer sehr hohe Ähnlichkeit zudem hat wovor das.
Die EU USA und das Vereinigte Königreich gewarnt haben sind es auf jeden Fall bekannt,
es werden Maßnahmen ergriffen sie sagen aber nicht welche sagen aber andererseits auch dass die Schwachstellen jetzt irgendwie nichts Neues gewesen wären die der zur Anwendung kommen dann fragt man sich natürlich auch wieder vivendi irgendwie Seiten ja bekannt sind und nichts Neues sind.
Mehrere Jahre alt und grundsätzlich bekannt warum haben wir die dann überhaupt noch,
ja und dann würde ich ja vermuten wenn irgendwann irgendwo jemand seinen Job richtig gemacht hat dann sind diese Schwachstellen hoffentlich nicht mehr vorhanden und dann sollte hier allenfalls diese diese Welle beobachtet werden und dann frage ich mich,
um irgendwie weltweit auf eine bekannte Schwachstelle zu gehen ja bei Geräten die am Internet hängen.
Der braucht mir doch keiner zu finanzieren dafür brauche ich irgendwie shudan unten Laptop.
Oder oder von mir aus den Server mit einer etwas besseren Anbindung da muss wohl doch keine Finanzierung durch den russischen Staat.
Was ist Shodan.
Also dann ist eine ist eine Suchmaschine für Geräte die bestimmte Dienste anbieten und oder unter diesen Dienst bestimmte Schwachstellen aufweisen.
Also kannst du irgendwie sowas machen wie webcam mit default password in Irland.
Dann kriegst du die Webcam mit default password in Irland und dann kannst du da drauf klicken.
Search.
Oder du sagst was weiß ich Cisco Router mit Software-Version Sohn zur also der Schwachstelle sowieso in folgendem Land kriegst du die unter gemeldet.
Soll ich.
Ein Facebook.
Facebook für Geräte zum IOT Facebook.
Facebook für das Internet der Dinge.
Ja sehr schön.
Genau.
Kann man auch gezielt Werbung reinschieben.
Webcam sieht irgendwie langweilig lustig wird erstmal wenn man auf die Beamer drauf kann.
Möchten Sie Ihren möchten Sie Ihren powerrouter möchtet ihr core Router von allen boost your listing.
Uwe so.
Also das ist natürlich ein bisschen irgendwie scheint mir das doch da einfach nur,
News um News zu machen zu sein wenn man wenn man solche Meldung kriegt ging Schwachstellen die ein Jahr alt sind sind wir hoffentlich gefallen wobei ich natürlich andersrum weiß sind wir nicht und es ist alles ganz ganz,
dramatische fürchterlich.
Ja das auch wirklich ein bisschen verstörend erst muss ich sagen also ich habe jetzt nicht bisher noch nicht sehr viel Anlass gehabt besondere Sympathie zu dem Gesamtverhalten von Russland am Tag zulegen,
allerdings ist dieses permanente der Russe steht vor der Tür Geschreie ja,
ohne dass man irgendwie das konkret belegen kann ist dass ich auch irgendwie stranger Zeit wo er living genau weil das ist so ein bisschen Wasser auch die wie früher also die ganzen und informierten,
Massen die halt so oben mit einigen wenigen wenigen Medien zugedeckt wurden und man das irgendwie überhaupt nicht überprüfen konnte verbirgt sich das ganze jetzt halt hinter so einem Schleier der Unsichtbarkeit weil man eben hier,
versucht aus welchem Netz vor gegen eine eine Botschaft herauszuführen die jetzt so schwer belegbar ist ne kann man nicht irgend,
so ist es.
Ich find das auch irgendwie anstrengend der andere also andauernd auch zu sagen,
Daten und das ist dann auch noch staatlich finanziert woher wollt ihr das denn wissen ja weiß ich meine Nachweis zu führen,
das ist aus einem Land kommt ist schon echt schwierig ja und dann aber noch zusammen die an einsam Hinweise dass das von Vladimir Putin aus der eigenen,
Tasche mit Rubel bezahlt wurde und wir also das ist immer ein bisschen sehr sehr sehr komisch da sollte man auf jeden Fall,
vorsichtig sein welche Beweise denn für solche Behauptung vorgelegt werden.
Und das ist eben selten der Fall.
Da gab es noch irgendwie eine Entscheidung gegen den CCC.
Ja leider.
Langer langer Streit zwischen CT und der Handelskammer Hamburg wo der CCC aufgrund des Hamburger Transparenzgesetz ist glaube ich eine der ersten Folgen Logbuch Netzpolitik da waren wir beim,
20 C3 oder so dann wir auch mit deutscher darüber gesprochen da trzic auf Erfüllung des Transparenzgesetz ist gegen die Handelskammer.
Hamburg geklagt und die hat aber gesagt das sieht sie nicht ein dass sie diese Daten offenlegen muss und das Hamburgische Oberverwaltungsgericht hat jetzt.
An diese die Berufungsklage abgelehnt und damit ist jetzt final unterlegen und sind keine weiteren rechts mit immer möglich.
Was hätte was hätte daraus geklagt werden sollen also welche neue Informationen wollte man gerne im Internet sehen.
Eine Ferdy die Sache ist hätte er gesagt werden sollen dass die Handelskammer dem Transparenzgesetz unterlegt und damit Ihre Daten und Dokumente im Internet zu veröffentlichen heiter.
Dem das hat sie sie hat gesagt sie hat ihre Rechtsauffassung vertreten dass sie die so eingesetzt nicht unterliegt.
Das Handy Handelskammer so rein rechtlich eigentlich.
Also ich würde tatsächlich gerne darauf verweisen dass wir dieses Thema mehrmals schon besprochen haben unter anderen im CCC Jahresrückblick und uns jetzt wirklich darauf bemühen das war jetzt hier mal bei den Kurzmeldung bleiben.
Alter du kannst mir leid knackige Antwort.
Also wir haben den Fall schon mehrmals besprochen als der tccd nämlich den ersten Instanz verloren,
also such mal da mal noch mal such mal dazu einfach noch mal die alten Sendung raus und ich bin jetzt langsam so ein bisschen unter Zeitdruck.
Sorry Russland hat gesagt wir blockieren einfach mal Telegramm den Messenger.
Er hat sich aber dann rausgestellt das ist nicht so einfach weil der in der Amazon Cloud ist die Amazon Cloud kann man nicht so einfach Locken da kriegt man unglückliche Internetnutzer.
Das ist eine ganz interessante Perspektive,
die seit einigen Jahren bemüht wird das man also quasi seine Dienste die die von Zensur betroffen sein können auf derartige Infrastruktur legt weil diese Amazon Cloud so gerne Ihre Haus nimmt und alpis einfach Wechseln,
dass man da quasi gegen eine dauerhafte Zensur dadurch arbeitet dass man sich auf diese auf diese Dienste legt auf deren Infrastruktur.
Ja aber sie wollen Sie bei uns gerne blockieren weil.
Das weiß ich noch nicht mal genau.
Wahrscheinlich weil achso weil Telegramm sich irgendeiner einem Zugriff durch staatliche Behörden entziehen also Russland wollte gerne Zugriff auf die Schlüssel haben.
Und das haben wir nicht bekommen und dann wurde von einem Gericht die umgehende Sperre des Chat Dienst ist angeordnet weil Telegramm sich der Aufforderung des Geheimdienstes FSB.
Nicht gebeugt hat Daten rausgeben.
Dann haben wir auch ein Stellengesuch.
Ja wir brauchen einen neuen Executive Director bei edry den.
Aktuellen Executive Director habt ihr ja vor wenigen Folgen hier gehört es ist Joe mcnamee,
und er hat Thomas hatte damals auch schon davor gewarnt er auch angekündigt dass er nach 10 Jahren aufhören wird das tut er jetzt auch wie angedroht.
Und das heißt wir suchen einen neuen Executive Director und das ist eine sehr sehr sehr wichtige.
Rolle.
Handy auf die man sich da bewerben kann bis zum 3. Juni 2018 also wenn euch da Leute einfallen die dieser.
Enormen ja politischen Kenntnis europäischen Kenntnis und so weiter genüge tun dann drängt sie doch mal dazu sich dort zu bewerben.
Genau sprachgewandt eloquent mehrsprachig nicht einfach.
Dann haben wir noch eine.
Eine schöne Meldung auf weißem Motherboard Info ein Drogendealer seine so quasi.
Um seine Drogen anzupreisen diese in seiner eigenen Hand fotografiert hat und die Polizei hat aus dem Foto dann den Fingerabdruck extrahieren und in ein geknetet.
Deswegen bitte nicht biometrische Merkmale oder oder zukünftig biometrisch identifizierbare Merkmale nutzen wenn ihr,
fotografieren und als Beweis für irgendwo reinstellen wenn irgendwas illegales macht Starbuck hatte davor vorher schon vor Jahren gewarnt in seinem Kongress Vortrag ich sehe also bin ich du.
Und wo er nämlich Ursula von der Leyen beim Diskutieren ihr wie fotografiert hat und damit dann auch mit erzählen in sie ein Fingerabdruck extrahiert hat.
Bist schon schön blöd irgendwie so die Pillen immer da verkauft in der eigenen Hand Sie bitte dazu reichen.
Aber vor paar Jahren wärst Du damit unter Umständen noch durchgekommen.
Vielleicht oder könnte sicherlich auch noch so einige einige Fälle rückwirkend aufgerollt werden.
So damit wären wir.
Damit werden wir bei den Terminen oder.
Diesmal sind relativ viele am Dienstag den 24. April das ist schon in wenigen Tagen in Berlin.
Er findet eine Veranstaltung der Gedenkstätte Berlin-Hohenschönhausen statt im Dienste der Unwahrheit fake-news gestern und heute in der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung.
Tiergartenstraße 35 los geht's am Dienstag 424 April um 18:30 Uhr und ich werde auch dort sein.
So da ist er reich immer sehr ankündigungs freundlich ist noch eine weitere Termin dort in Wien finden die Linux Wochen statt vom 3. bis 5. Mai 2018 Linuxwochen.
ATS Lesch Wien im FH Technikum Wien freier Eintritt und niedrigschwellige Torx.
Ganz toll qualitativ hochwertig alles zu finden und das ganze ist organisiert von der Gruppe Quintessenz.
Und im direkten Anschluss an diese Linuxwochen findet dann auch noch die Maker Faire Vienna Stadt 5. bis 6. Mai in Wien also da,
lohnt sich jetzt mal die Reise jetzt bin ich ganz irritiert ob du die den Termin vom 27 April absichtlich übergangen hast oder ob ich dir noch reinwerfen darf.
Ach so den habe ich nicht absichtlich übergangen wen habe ich.
27 April in Berlin die systemkonform Soli Party,
mit Workshops und Party gegen Überwachung startet um 20 Uhr mit Vorträgen Workshops und Kurzfilm zum Thema und ab 23:59 Uhr geht's denn los mit,
Techno Deep House & downbeat Eintritt fürs Vorprogramm ist umsonst für die Party dann 10 € und die Spenden gehen komplett an Amnesty.
International und digitale Freiheit für die Finanzierung weiterer Aktion.
Zurück in den Mai am 10. Mai auch bekannt als Himmelfahrt gibt es in Bayern einen großen Prozesstag gegen das neue polizeiaufgabengesetz dass wir hier in der letzten Sendung auch beleuchtet haben was da alles schief läuft,
und da gibt's Landeswald Großdemos und da könnt ihr euch dann umfangreich beteiligen.
Und am 18.05 bis 21.05 findet das aktiv Symposium München im Münchner CCC Stadt,
es geht Freitag Abend los mit geselligen grillen und dann gibt's Samstag und Sonntag Workshops,
Samstag abends gibt's die traditionelle. Bar mit Lounge und am Sonntag feiert der TTC München dann auch noch zehn Jahre Räumlichkeiten das heißt es ist viel los bis dann am Montag,
das Abschlussgrillen und große Aufräumen stattfindet auch da weitere,
links bei uns in den schauen aus und wir freuen uns euch auch in München an zu Besuch begrüßen.
Aktiv Symposium sehr schön.
Das war irgendwie glaube ich mal so eine Divan knatschig weil sie den easterhegg nicht bekommen hatten und weil sie das weil sie das aber solange schon irgendwie vorbereitet haben haben sie dann gesagt wir machen wir trotzdem.
Irgendwie so kannst aktiv Symposium glaube ich ins Leben mit sich wenn ich die Sache richtig erinnere.
Ist gut so das bringt uns ans Ende der Sendung du musst jetzt auch los und aber wie ich Dich kenne hast du noch ein paar Danksagung am Start.
Ich habe Danksagungen an Michael Markus Thorsten und Christopher die mir große Freude bereitet haben die Paketboten hingegen nicht immer schlimmer.
Dann aber gleich auf Twitter noch richtig schön gegen die roten hetzen wenn sie nicht da.
Nee nein die tut mir auch leid aber,
die tut mir leid weil die da die wenn ja echt gehetzt und es ist wirklich ein undankbarer Job und da muss echt mal was passieren dass die,
dass die Unternehmen diese Tätigkeit wieder auf ein zumutbares Niveau stellen in den Sie mehr Leute anstellen und den weniger Stress machen dass sie in der Lage sind wenigstens mal so ein Zelt zu hinterlassen unser Haus ist tapeziert,
tapeziert mit Hilfe wo ist mein Paket,
jeden Tag 5 Emails von Leuten die irgendwie was weiß ich einige Blutkonserven bestellt hat Mutti nicht kriegen oder so ne wirklich fürchterlich.
Kleiner Tipp Polen den Kunden Kundennummer bei deinem Paket abholen Büro um die Ecke lass da alles hinschicken und dann.
Habe ich auch versucht hat nicht funktioniert kommt auch zurück finden die nicht die wissen nicht wo die.
Das direkt mit einer Nummer ist.
Na diese Postbox da ist.
Mein alter Paketbote der der bei uns immer zuständig war ganz ganz guter Mann der hat seine Aufgabe mit Ruhe mit.
Mit mit mit Leistungsbereitschaft mit Freundlichkeit das war ein großartiger,
Typ der sich immer darum gekümmert hat den haben jetzt offen bei ihr woanders hin versetzt der fährt jetzt gerade woanders der war in die sind an diesem Ding da zugange und sagte ja tut mir leid Herr Neumann erkennt mich natürlich auch sagt er tut mir leid ne weil se weil es einer ist ist es aus der alten Schule,
Alfred Potter und der Savannen sind Dinge sagt ja tut mir leid sie können jetzt zwei Stunden lang ist reintun,
weil ich jetzt zwei Stunden mit beschäftigt bin die Dinger ganzen Dinger aufzumachen und neue Dinge rein zu tun und dann wenn ich alles reingepasst hat bisschen dicker nach Osten zu fahren weil die hat unterdimensioniert ist oder zur nächsten Paket also dass die Logistik explodiert gerade und die haben es einfach nicht im Griff.
Ja ich rede aber auch nicht von diesem automatischen Boxen sollen ich rede einfach von diesem Café,
Büroreinigung Läden und so weiter da gibt's ja immer was in der in der unmittelbaren Umgebung mittlerweile und da kann man sich halt teilweise auch schon so richtig eine Nummer klicken.
Ja das Problem das ist sehr schön das Problem ist wenn du keine notification darüber bekommst wenn du dir selber was bestellst dann weißt du ja wenigstens das wurde jetzt zugestellt.
Wenn es aber etwas ist was du nicht aktiv bestellt hast von dem du nicht weißt ob und wann es kommt.
Ein anderes Problem aber dann kam das zumindest immer mal vorbei gehen und fragen ob irgendwie bei der Nummer was ist wenn es bei dir ich hol den Hauseingang ist das ist ja zu machen Seite na ja.
Du hast keine Vorstellung wie diese Läden wir uns aussehen die haben die.
Doch habe ich.
Ich kenne deinen Bezirk na ja aber wir können unsere first World problems vielleicht später weiter diskutieren jetzt,
so nämlich los und diese Sendung will ja auch veröffentlicht werden das dauert auch noch ein bisschen ich bedanke mich auch noch mal bei allen die die Sendung und die Metaebene unterstützen und wir melden uns bald wieder wir müssen ja noch die 255 voll bekommen damit wir uns dann,
mit euch schön ins Babylon setzen kann.
Ja und wir freuen uns wenn ihr da erscheint so danke schön das war's ich muss Schluss mit ciao ciao.
Macht ja nix bis dann.